[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui sur terre on est sept
milliards d'habitants en 2050 on sera 10
milliards d'habitants
forcément qui dit augmentation de la
population mondiale dit l'augmentation
de la demande en nourriture plus de ça
les habitudes alimentaires évoluent et
la consommation en viande devrait
doubler d'ici cinq ans ce jour là du
coup on va se poser la question comment
va-t-on faire pour réussir à nourrir
tout le monde en 2050
la réponse la plus évidente cela veut
dire ça va être produire plus et un peu
compliqué que ça empêche faut savoir que
les sources actuelles de nutrition de
produits comme par exemple les pages
bien la pêche c'est un fort impact sur
l'environnement
je vends combiné c'est un biais négatif
du clown question en fait comment
réussir un logo tout le monde en 2005
ans ça a pu devenir
comment réussir à nourrir le monde en
2050 de manière durable éco responsable
alors on s'est creusé la tête on a
cherché plusieurs réponses
et parmi ces réponses la haye farocki et
l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture a sorti
un rapport dans lequel elle préconise
elle propose d'utiliser les insectes
comme nouvelle source de 1600 nouvelles
sources de côté on doit le dire pourquoi
les insectes pour éviter des sorties du
chapeau comme ça on va il faut savoir
que les insectes en aidant potentiel
tant sur le côté nutritifs que sur le
côté environnemental vous donner les
plus ordre d'idée quelques chiffres
comprend par exemple le côté effectif
les nids d'insectes sont super riches en
protéines par exemple dans les clients
ou les vers de farine on a 50 % de
protéines
ces deux à trois fois puisque d'argent
couche même dans la manche
en plus de ça les insectes for me
en italie en fer en zinc oméga 3 oméga 6
ils contiennent tous les acides aminés
essentiels pour le corps qu'on doit
consommer tous les jours
en bref les insectes parfaite
alternative à la jambe en plus de ça
davantage des insectes sexy des super
écolo vous donnez là aussi quelques
chiffres
par exemple pour produire 1 kg à sec
on va utiliser 2 kg de nourriture pour
produire 1 kg de viande bovine en or
utilisées 10 kg de nourriture donc
l'endroit qui a un intérêt en termes de
rendement ça les insectes
concrètement ils vont être pas très
regardant sur la marchandise qu'on leur
donne par exemple on va leur donner les
faits lui moche on va pouvoir valoriser
en fait des productions qu'on peut pas
valorisées dans les cellules classiques
des discussions et concrètement ensuite
donné une carotte trop grande trop petit
pas droit à un client allemand henkel a
mangé m'accabler mais ça va lui poser
aucun problème ça les insectes sont pas
assez gourmand au nombre par exemple il
n'ya pas d'abord voir pour des gagnants
ya pas d'aveu voir tous les vers de
farine les insectes si on s'hydrate et
qu'avec les fruits et légumes qu'on va
leur donner notre avantage de l'élevage
d'insectes
c'est qu'on va pouvoir réduire de 90 9 %
en moins la pollution les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre déjà premièrement
parce que les insectes
très peu de gaz à effet de serre dans
tout ça les sectes et l'optimiser en
fait on va limiter les transports on va
limiter les déplacements et dans les
élevages d'insectes on va aussi réaliser
la partie transformation valorisation
des vingt sept
en plus de ces trois avantages fiscaux
les insectes ont plein d'autres
avantages
par exemple il ya aussi un gain de temps
pour les u19 qu'ils soient adultes
valoir de deux ans à peu près de temps
pour les insectes suivant les espèces
d'insectes et si les bonnes conditions
sont réunies on va avoir une nouvelle
génération sec tous les pains à devant
en plus de salles une femelle est
capable de vendre plusieurs jeunes
je laisse imaginer sur le calcul avec
les possibilités qu'on peut avoir à
limoges d'insectes en termes d'évolution
de la population du cheptel de recettes
en plus de ça c'est intéressant
en plus du bien de temps aux abords
d'une page par exemple si vous avez une
pièce de 10 mètres carrés vous allez
pouvoir essayer dans cette pièce à
plusieurs dizaines de kilos d'insectes
par mois qu'un dernier point qui est
intéressant par rapport aux insectes et
à l'élevage d'insectes
c'est le risque de transmission de
maladies le savez très bien les danses
excentris douaniers de nous d'un point
de vue en sait trop où on va dire en
scellant cette c'était très lointains
ancêtres et en fait grâce à ça le risque
de transmission de maladies est très
éloigné il ya peu de chances que manger
des insectes on attrape une maladie
alors comment j'en ai plein pour ne plus
avoir la grippe
au moins gens du peuple à l'avis du
conseil d'école du coup là vous devez
sûrement vous dire que les insectes
c'est super sûrement top
ils ont des supers propriété c'est
l'avenir de notre alimentation est là on
entend des insectes au reste de la
planète
vous devez aussi vous poser une question
en fait pourquoi tout simplement entre
pas les insectes déjà partout dans tous
les magasins et qu'on peut acheter un
autre
il ya plusieurs réponses à cette
question une réponse réglementaire et si
nous les réponses qu au final juste pas
installé en plein en france et parmi ces
dépenses il ya aussi la réponse de la
culture alimentaire en fait tout
simplement vous savez les insectes
cultures alimentaires en nombre et en
france et déjà il faut savoir une chose
c'est que les insectes sont consommés
par plus de deux milliards d'habitants
sur terre quotidiennement
que ce soit en afrique en asie ou voir
même en amérique centrale présente sans
pelli légende l'a pas à manger des
insectes quotidiennement par des cécités
par plaisir et douanières culturel
en plus de ça il faut aussi savoir que
les insectes concrètement et des
consommables à l'époque de l'antiquité
il se faisait des places à 2 de grille
en jeu les gammes chez romain voilà
comme j'ai dit vous savez que les
insectes ne sont pas encore dans notre
culture alimentaire le bois ou en france
mange quand même des grenouilles on va
et manger des moules
on va quand même manger des crevettes
des huîtres fois par an des déclics et
faut pas manger des grillons près tous
en fête ses cousins et cousines welling
quand même déclaré fléchi et on s'est
dit comment réussir à intégrer le
lendemain
l'entomophagie signifie le fait de
manger des insectes
comment réussir à intégrer
l'entomophagie dans notre culture
alimentaire dans notre quotidien
en fait on a décidé d'y aller manière
progressive si demain j'oubliais à
manger de la viande
je vous servir des insectes après ça je
pense que vous n'allez pas trop apprécié
ça va être contre-productive à l'idrac
et on va pas y arriver
donc l'idée c'est de proposer différents
produits pour petit à petit réussi à
intégrer cette consommation d'insectes
intégrer les insectes à la fois dans
notre culture et dans nos assiettes
le premier produit qu'on a essayé de
sortir chez les insectes halak alors
ceux qui savent pas se laisser des
insectes à bureaux ça va être par
exemple des grêlons ou des vers de
farine on va déjà raté pour les rangs
des super coup ci on y apprend vallée
plupart et avec différentes épices on
peut par exemple déprimant au curry ont
fait par exemple des vers de farine à
l'oignon est en fait le principe de
proposer les insectes à la qualif
l'objectif avec ça cd proposé un moment
sympa et proposait un moment fort où
vous êtes entre avec vos amis ou avec
votre famille et c'est un moment fait on
est prêt à rester nouvelles choses a
ajouté de nouveaux produits et en plus
de ça avec l'effet de groupe on est prêt
à oser se lancer est allé tester de
nouvelles choses donc composé des
insectes à l'apéritif
ça permet une première approche une
première démocratisation première et
dramatisation mal de la consommation 27
et ça permet à ça permet de prouver en
fait là tout le monde est déjà corps
peut manger des insectes
et puis dauphine allemand j'ai des
insectes c'est beaucoup en plus de ça
nous ont crié c'est arrivé à intégrer
les insectes de manière quotidienne
tentation on peut par contre les
insectes parce que c'est des insectes re
manger des insectes pour leurs intérêts
punitifs
donc on a réfléchi et on a décidé
proposés on fait souvent en forme
on a dix sites proposés les insectes en
tout dans cet avantage de proposer des
insectes en poudre
il ya plusieurs avantages déjà on va
supprimer l'aspect visuel
concrètement en bien en supprimant
l'aspect visuel
ça va permettre de supprimer aussi le
frein psychologique qu'ont certaines
personnes d'être ça commente ou dans la
salle de mangeurs d'insectes
quand ils le voient pas menti en plus de
ça en supprimant l'aspect visuel on doit
aussi supprimer le goûter des filles
côté spectacle que personne l'un que le
certaines personnes membres avant à
consommer des insectes
on peut les faire koh lanta en plus de
ça et ça c'est la branche principale en
révisant les insectes en contre ça nous
permet en fait de les intégrer dans
plein de paix parce ça nous permet de
les intégrer dans plein de recettes déjà
avec six ans
avec ça on a pu faire les préparations
sucrées on a fait par exemple écouter
aux vers de farine on a fuit départ d'un
serial lyon mais aussi on n'a plus les
intégrer dans des préparations salées
on a fait par exemple les boulettes
millions ou même des steaks aux vers de
farine avec l'intérêt de proposer
différents produits de proposer
différentes approches
c'est vous permettre de faciliter de
réussir à intégrer petit à petit la
consommation d'insectes avec différentes
approches et s'adapter aux goûts de
chacun monté qu'au final les insectes en
potentiel vraiment global et c'est là
qu'ils aiment c'est simple on voit qu au
final les insectes arrivent petit à
petit à s'intégrer dans notre futur
alimentaire et s'intégrer aussi dans
notre quotidien
déjà on voit que les médias parlent de
plus en plus des insectes
que ce soit les articles de presse sur
internet qui traitent du sujet ou alors
le documentaire à la télévision
il ya aussi les particuliers de chacun
d'entre vous qui vont s'intéresser à la
cuisse maxent insectes qui vont même en
acheter ce soit l'apéritif que ce soit
des produits déjà transformé comme par
exemple départ initial ou même il faut
ajouter 1,5 pour les cuisiner eux-mêmes
mais surtout et c'est là qu'on voit qu
un grand pas a été réalisée les
professionnels de la gastronomie vont
intégrer les insectes dans des recettes
dans deux places
on travaille par exemple avec des
traiteurs on travaille par exemple avec
des restaurateurs où il ya même des
chefs étoilés français qui ont décidé
d'intégrer des insectes dans leurs
recettes
ils ont fait par exemple de battisti
comme des macarons ou payants dont ils
ont fait même des glaces salées comme
par exemple des risottos aux vers de
farine
du coup si on devait reprendre notre
problématique comment réussir à nourrir
toute la planète en 2050 de manière
durable éco responsable et j'ai plus
conseil à vous donner en fait d'arriver
à oser barils à vous lancer et puis en
fait de consommer un petit globe a sauvé
la tablette merci
[Applaudissements]